i want to talk about squid game yeah we
should talk about squid game yeah what
about it so i think squid game is
i i don't think it's overtly political
apparently you know you were telling me
uh gary that it was like there's like a
political message in squid yeah the
writer at least that's what he said my
takeaway from it was communism bad
that was my take away from it
okay so now i'm going to say this for
those that are listening spoiler alert
if you haven't finished squid game it's
an awesome show yeah i prefer watching
it in a the original korean with with
subtitles i think it's fantastic with
the dub you lose a lot of that like
reverb and like natural sound it's kind
of weird
uh so spoiler alert i'm going to say it
again we are going to spoil this show to
uh the
kingdom come there we go spoiler alert
uh so what what what was it about you
mentioned that the creator had said
something and it was like the creator
called it a fable for uh modern day
capitalism uh but also for life and the
competitiveness of life uh and that
message it's it's not subtle at the end
uh which i won't ruin for anybody but
it's not subtle at the end and that
messaging was there and you know some
people can't get past it and i
understand that but i thought it was a
damn good so what what was the messaging
like what do you think the message
conveyed well it's that it's a basically
it's a cold and cruel system they're in
that fable you know there is no
resolution except for at the end they
create their own enemy quote unquote but
um that's what i got out of it all right
all right
uh just for context okay because those
of you that are sticking around even
though we told you spoilers are here i'm
gonna give you the quick breakdown of
the of the show it's a bunch of
desperate people in debt and then all of
a sudden they get an opportunity to play
in a game
but the game is brutal and you die in it
but if you don't you win i think i think
it's like equivalent of us like 35 to 40
million dollars is a translation so it's
like 45 billion korean won or something
now we're gonna get into uh again i warn
you spoilers i think the whole thing is
the perfect example of
somebody who thinks they're opposing
capitalism but just makes communism and
wokeness look really really dumb
and the show ends up being in my opinion
more anti-communist than anything so one
of the big themes in the show is that
everyone is equal
they all enter the game as equals and
they're allowed to play as equals and
there's an arc in the show where it's
like somebody violates the equality and
so they kill him and they were like
that's the worst thing you could have
done is strip the equality but now
here's how the show ends you've been
warned
in this equal system everyone dies but
one person who gets all of the money
okay so that doesn't sound to me like
capitalism in capitalism we recognize
not everybody is equal not everybody
does have an equal chance we do want
equal opportunity but some people are
poor and some people are rich in this
system everyone is wearing the same
clothes in the same room being
brutalized by by the powers that
ultimately results in one person having
all the wealth and everyone dying that
is not capitalism in capitalism there's
too much food people are morbidly obese
and there are there are homeless people
who are fat in communism everybody wears
the same clothes they have limited
access to anything they get garbage food
every day they're like okay the game's
over here's the food you get and they
get trash
and they're fighting each other because
they're starving that to me is an
indictment of communism and if this guy
who made the show is actually like it's
it's actually capitalism that's bad i'm
like it just goes to show this is a
person who made a great show but was
really dumb and didn't understand they
were actually critiquing communism it's
like they took them out of a
capitalistic system where they were
doing pretty bad to a communistic system
where they were doing really really
badly
and were executed by the state which
usually happens under communism uh i
mean for like childish whims exactly and
and that's literally what happens under
communism uh look up uh you know what
happened in china what happened in
russia what happened in uh you know in
europe as well so there's a long history
there's a long context to you know
people just being purged taken away
another very interesting aspect of that
story is the masks that the very rich
people were wearing were kind of similar
to
the same masks that the rothschilds were
pictured wearing at some of their
private parties and gals a couple
decades ago so i i saw that right away i
was like wait wait wait that's that's
that's the elites doing this and uh you
know i i thought i thought of the movie
more of a critique
about the the ruling elites uh because
it's it's essentially again spoiler rich
people coming together to watch the
average poor people struggling people
kill each other over money um and and
you know there's some important kind of
parallels there the movie i'm sorry the
series is kind of gory so if you're
sensitive to that stuff i wouldn't i
want to watch it i watched i was like
tim you got to watch it right
but but it it you watched it and it is
very top provoking it is very emotional
um and it definitely pulls at the
heartstrings in many different ways i
looked this up lukey ain't kidding what
is it there's a there's a bunch of
photos from this rothschild party where
they're all wearing these masks that are
similar to the squid game thing but
that's probably what he was doing the
creator
yeah it was a guy right who created it
i'm saying well the story i'm hearing a
lot of different i'm hearing a lot of
different reports about this guy saying
that he lost a bunch of teeth because of
the stress during the production of this
movie i heard that he tried to get this
movie done for years and it kept getting
denied
so uh the series you mean yeah yeah yeah
the the series uh but but yeah i
remember seeing those masks
automatically thinking wait wait wait i
know i saw these masks before they're at
the private gallows and private meetings
of the super rich that already do take
place when you do look at the very
powerful people in our world that
manipulate the system
capitalism isn't the problem
communism doesn't exist it's just this
idealized system we might as well call
it unicornism the real problem is
corruption and corporatism and the left
says capitalism when they mean
corporatism i think that's exactly the
problem i think that's what he's doing
with the masks he thinks that the
rothschilds embody capitalism they do
not know they embody elitism they're the
biggest promoters and pushers of
communism and this destroyers of actual
real uh you know free markets uh another
interesting aspect was the fat guy i
mean he looked almost exactly like newt
gingrich i talked to newt gingrich a
couple times i went up to him asked him
straight up to his face hey what did you
do at the bohemian grove when you
shipped in specifically male prostitutes
uh and he was sweating up a storm i did
this like five times to him he really
doesn't like being asked those questions
but we gotta understand here there is
some level of reality when it comes to
super rich people coming together in the
middle of the woods doing very weird
things that does happen it's called the
bohemian grove there's also other kind
of secret societies and offshoots to
these secret societies remember when
bilderberg was a conspiracy theory yeah
they said it didn't exist they said it
didn't exist a few years ago and i was
there at the meetings be like it's here
it's happening they're like no he's
crazy remember when they sent that dude
from the guardian down he was really
charlie skelton he came there to make
fun he's now my friend charlie skelton
was sit down there by the guardian to
make fun of the people outside they sent
him down there there he's like there's a
bunch of loonies there's a bunch of
crazies he literally got followed
everywhere assaulted by police officers
they raided his hotel room they raided
my hotel room the police officers acted
like the gestapo against any journalist
trying to do any real reporting against
the bilderberg group and he came out of
it shook saying hey i thought these guys
were crazy i came here to make fun of
them these guys are honest i'm being
followed by police everywhere i go and
they're literally trying to arrest me
for just trying to take a photo of of
david rockefeller and henry kissinger
walking down the street together i got
arrested at bilderberg way too many
times too uh i said it wasn't real i
said it was yeah it doesn't exist and
it's like you could literally just stand
there be like here it is
and they'd be like sorry sir it's a
private event it's the bilderberg you
know group meeting and and then look in
the newspaper and it's like nope not a
real thing doesn't exist crazy yeah i
remember there being being like this is
absolutely absurd but but when really
rich people do come together they do
really weird stuff and there's a lot of
weird stuff that i i i even experienced
that bilderberg there's even weirdest
stuff happening at the bohemian grove
and this is some of the stuff we know
about what about the stuff we don't know
about so i think i thought this this was
a perfect time to talk about the bigger
elements of these elites who do very
sinister things so that's that was me
the larger conversation of squid games
but that's always the criticism is
always the corrupt elites i don't you
know when they talk about like oh
communism
they never actually implement because
it's not possible it's impossible to do
and then when they criticize when when
the left criticizes capitalism they're
really just angry there are there
they're elites with centralized power
able to do really messed up things and
get away with it because of how much
power they've accumulated
that's not what capitalism is supposed
to represent either and the problem is
communism doesn't exist right they say
that like they every time they try it
they get some weird form of you know
genocidal authoritarianism capitalism at
its root is just people with capital
from their work can reinvest that into
making more projects however in our
current system which mixes it we end up
with a lot of corruption and then you
get a left saying ah this proves
capitalism doesn't work and it's like no
actually the problem is is the
corruption yeah i don't care who who's
doing it or why corruption bad when you
use the power of government to destroy
your competitors in the quote free
market that's not a free market that's
not the fact that that's communism
that's government direct intervention
into the free market that's preventing
the market from being able to express
itself from being able to speak for
itself because usually in the free
market if someone does something good
they get promoted they get business they
get commerce they get people going to
them because they know that their
reputation is good when you have
multi-national billionaire elites
playing by a different set of rules not
paying taxes getting subsidies literally
getting taxpayer-funded money getting
bailouts and restrictions and rules that
punish their competitors and only help
them that is not a free market we don't
have that we have multinational
corporations globalists some people call
them that are literally the ones calling
the shots creating policies that screw
you over while they get whatever they
want for the grabbing thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you